one day there will be a final death toll
from Hurricane Ian that's their job
this is a search team on the streets of
Fort Myers in Florida
looking for the people who didn't make
it
the longer they work the larger the
number
some places in Florida are harder to
reach than others you know I think
everybody's in shock nobody really knows
what's going to happen or what's going
on honestly Andrew Williams took us on
his boat to Pine Island the route the
hurricane took it showed
onshore is Devastation on the water are
Islanders under evacuation by a flotilla
of vessels Dunkirk by Design there's
been constant traffic to and from the
island all day with Emergency Services
stretched across this state this has all
been done by private Boat Owners it's
the people's evacuation
on Pine Island we saw the bridge the
hurricane broke and cut off this place
there was no stopping the waves here
[Music]
thank you
it is Eerie on parts of this island
a shell of what it was we have no power
we have no water
we have no cell phone we have nothing
out there
five days on many have left Pine Island
though some defiantly stay behind
you know someone else said
a picture's worth a thousand words well
being here is
leaves me speechless we're on our own I
think and um
we're not leaving
not anytime soon why not
sour Island
[Music]
this was the first Sunday after the
storm and a time to reflect
[Music]
you cannot be exhausted the pastor
preached resilience inside New Hope
Baptist Church foreign
the mobile kitchens spoke of the same
everyone here has had to adapt like one
member of this congregation who works as
a nurse at a nearby hospital
to be a life or death surgery just
because we want to make sure conditions
are optimal we don't want to put
somebody's life in danger because we
don't have adequate
supplies or running water electricity
those types of things so we've had to be
very careful
[Music]
it is coming to terms with life after
the hurricane
and it isn't easy
James Matthews Sky News in Florida